so you can't absolutely prove the
existence of God but the consequences of
denying the existence of God as a
theoretical postulate at least is a
system of physics which ends up eating
its own which ends up destroying her
epistemological reasons our ability to
rely on our own reasoning capabilities
about the world around us so at the end
the choices between God and science or
no God and no signs welcome everybody to
this episode of the into the impossible
podcast and today I am joined by a very
interesting individual someone I have
spoken about before uh on the podcast
and in my day job as a practicing
cosmologist
and and that is uh Dr Stephen Meyer who
is joining us he is at The Discovery
Institute and I will give a proper
introduction to him as we go on but the
occasion of today's podcast interview
which is years in the making because
I've known of his work for many many
years I've followed him and admired what
he does and the role that he plays in
the philosophy of science and even in as
you'll find out intelligent design what
is this Keating a respected cosmologist
is now getting into intelligent design
well you'll find out and uh as I said in
the incomia that I gave to this new book
by our wonderful guest today called The
Return of the god hypothesis Stephen C
Meyer he's the author of The Breakaway
best-selling book Darwin's doubt the
signature in the cell many other books
and uh works of a really Outreach and
scientific communication and it's such a
treat to to be with you today Stephen
and I'm so I'm so enamored of uh your
prodigious workload how do you do it how
do you possibly do this uh tremendous
output that you do and uh and still have
some semblance of sanity left over well
I could ask you the same thing actually
with your practicing day job at the
Forefront of cosmology and also working
on putting out uh very very fine books
yourself so uh it's it's once I got
liberated from full-time teaching I was
able to write quite a bit more so that's
been the secret I think I was a
professor for 12 years and then came to
Discovery and been more focused on the
research right so I want to just read
your quick bio that I received and
um this should be familiar to many of my
listeners because they may have
encountered you already in your debates
with none other than upcoming guest uh
uh Dr Lawrence Krauss of the origins
project and the origins podcast
hopefully Lawrence is coming on not too
long but none Lawrence plays a not
insignificant role in the god hypothesis
I wonder did you send him an advanced uh
copy of this book
I I will send it out okay good yeah
we'll get him aside I think he and I
have dueling essays in a journal
inference uh coming up soon oh wow okay
so I received a copy he's a where where
are the intellectual interlocutor for
sure yes that's right and uh and the The
Odd Couple if ever there were one uh so
I received this book in the mail at UCSD
and and I and I opened it up and I said
oh Stephen's got a new book I didn't
know that back in it was December 7th I
know uh because it's a day that will
live in infamy for many reasons and uh I
got this book and said Stephen Meyer
received his PhD from Cambridge
University in the philosophy of science
a former geophysicist and college
professor he directs the Center for
Science and culture at the discovery in
Seattle he authored the New York Times
bestselling Darwin style signature in
the cell uh which was selected as uh
near as a London Times literary
supplement book of the year it's been
featured on PBS Ben Shapiro et cetera et
cetera and it said Professor Keating you
know we we
um we're so pleased to present to you
this Galley copy so this is not the
original copy and it said um uh we'd be
so pleased if you'd get us uh some
comment on the book uh by December 15th
and you know Stephen doesn't write books
by the pound but but if he did he'd be
even more uh replete and uh munificently
remunerated then he has this book is
like 600 pages long so I I can't do that
I you got to give me at least eight days
nine days Stephen come on um but uh but
actually I tore through it of course I
look up my name and it um and uh she
made sure that I was featured
prominently as a couple of chapters
befitting my my own personal respondents
uh but uh this book is so thoroughly
researched it really is kind of like a
mini PhD in the philosophy of science it
is dense I took billions of notes on the
hard copy I'm gonna get the audiobook
version but I want to first start off
with the question that my audience is
going to ask why are you on this show
why are you an intelligent design
Advocate on a show with a practicing
cosmologist who professes that he is a
devout practicing agnostic on not an
infrequent basis so what makes you and
some of the work that you do what brings
attention maybe even controversy to the
work that you do well one of the things
that that you've said that I like is
that you're an agnostic who wrestles
with God you're interested in the big
questions and I am too and I think
that's a common uh interest that we have
what does science have to say about
these larger metaphysical or worldview
issues if anything I think it actually
has quite a lot to say and I think there
are design implications in cosmology and
physics every bit as much as in in
biology I think we do live in a universe
that has evidence of design and purpose
and I think that that means that science
may have some Clues as to some of those
uh the answers to some of those big
questions and so I hope that that makes
some sense to your audience but
certainly I think in our conversations
has been one of the things that has
drawn us together
absolutely yeah we've had really um deep
conversations and as you know I'm uh
practicing Jew I'm not Orthodox devout
uh Orthodox but I do adhere to the some
of the tenants most of the tenants in my
faith you know it's been a long time I I
haven't you know uh slept with my uh
with my with my grandmother's uh you
know ex-husband or say you know they're
all these mitts vote in the Torah and
people say I can't keep it I can't keep
all those Commandments and I say you
know did you sleep with your with your
Stepmother's wife or you know whatever
and it's it's actually not that hard to
uh to adhere to some of these things you
know you don't you don't have to do that
much you know find a red heifer and kill
it that's not something we have to do on
a daily basis but uh but the
conversation that we had I'll just start
off by saying the thing that worried me
about
um about this book and even you know
conversing with folks like you or
William is it William Lane Craig or
William Craig Lane I always forget
William Lane Craig
you always get this sort of uh sense as
a as a scientist Jewish or not not you
know that there will be the following
progression uh it'll start off with the
column cosmological argument that you
know anything that has a beginner uh
must have or anything that began must
have had a beginning and must perhaps
have a beginner so cosmology the Big
Bang the universe had a beginning
therefore there must have been a banger
as one of my rabbis says uh the big
banger is is the uh is the force the
motive Force to put the bang in the Big
Bang and then it'll be well because uh
God wouldn't create the universe without
some sense of purpose and design they're
in it is in effect a personal God okay
so that might follow logically from a
supposition that column is right or that
this argument is sound and then it will
always be and therefore Jesus and it's
very difficult as a you know practicing
too not to deny the historicity
um The Magnificent teachings of Jesus
the authenticity of Jesus's life and his
teaching we as you know as Jews document
exquisitely the teachings of all of our
rabbis going back thousands of years and
and Jesus was of course one of the most
preeminent uh exemplars of that
tradition
um so I always find it interesting and
and a little bit perilous to engage with
Christian
uh people that are scientifically
inclined to want to support the
hypothesis that Jesus more than the god
hypothesis the Jesus hypothesis so can
you say something about that can you
believe can you read this book which is
as I said thoroughly documented details
the biological cosmological and physical
implications of the evidence for design
can you accept the contents of this book
written by Christian uh devout Christian
if you're not Christian and perhaps have
no no you know position on the ACT on
the legitimacy of Christ as Messiah yeah
uh are you and I have something else in
common which is that um you're kind of a
a Christian friendly Jewish person and
I'm a Jewish friendly Christian person
and I have a lot of a lot of close
colleagues in our work at Discovery who
are
Jewish and um I don't think you can
settle questions
specific religious questions with it
especially within the context of theism
through appeals to Nature
um I think the theologians make a
distinction between General and special
Revelation and the the uh the kind of
arguments that I'm making are based on
the general revelation of Nature and I
don't think they they settle
um those differences between Jews and
Christians or non-religious theists and
Muslims or uh those other sorts of
considerations would have to come into
play and those conversations would have
to occur separately so this is a book
simply about well simply it's a big
topic first the evidence of design but
then it also addresses uh a second order
not addressed before which is uh what
what can science tell us about the
possible identity of the designing
intelligence responsible for life for
example
so that's that that might get you to
theism I argue that it does but uh it
doesn't get you further than that within
the framework of theism
um uh or some sort of transcendent
intelligence uh then there's there's
other sorts of questions that would
require further deliberation that can't
be I think uh settled by by appeals to
Nature
and of course you know this is not a new
topic people have been kind of looking
at the confrontation is is religion
engaged in a Perpetual battle against
science and and some of those uh come
down to what uh the late great uh
Stephen J Gould called Noma
non-overlapping magisterial
um uh support and I actually um I've
never been a huge fan of that I always
kind of find that rather Bland and I and
that's not to say I haven't used that
argument myself I frequently have said
you know if you pick up a book and it
says you know great the stars of the NBA
and and you look through it and it's 999
pages of the you know seven Jews who
have ever made it to the NBA and there's
one page about everybody else uh then
you would say well this is not really an
accurate title for the book and and yet
that same ratio takes place in the Bible
in the Old Testament at least the The
Testament I'm most familiar with in that
there's about 35 verses that plausibly
have to do with evolution in or the Big
Bang or creation of the universe out of
000 verses so there's that same ratio of
one to a thousand
um and yet people want to kind of
pigeonhole it as saying a couple of
scientific things here a couple of you
know a couple of uh of of
biological claims here over there and I
really feel like that's the most that's
the that's the deepest clue that they're
it's not just that they're not
overlapping it's that they're totally
irrelevant it's like picking up a book
on Quantum field Theory and expecting to
find a way to raise your kids so what is
it about Noma is it just because of
Stephen J Gould's you know amazing
personality and communication of science
is there something actually there that
is more than you know than just kind of
feel good you do what you want to do
I'll do what I want to do because I
always say if God exists
you're going to act very differently
than if God doesn't exist if you know
God doesn't exist so just tolerating it
you know giving it lip service as Noma
appeals to at least in my understanding
of it um I don't find it very satisfying
is it is it legitimate in some sense it
well there's I think there's legitimacy
in it there's an old uh uh saw from
Galileo you know the Bible tells us how
to go to heaven not how the heavens go
and that is to say much of what we call
the Natural Sciences concerns questions
that are religiously neutral you know
what's the formula for assault what's
the the the uh so given reaction
sequence or uh the the specific form of
the law of gravity or whatever but there
are uh there are questions that science
raises that do have larger philosophical
worldview religious implications uh what
is a law of nature uh from when from
whence did the universe come uh what
caused the universe to come into
existence
um and so there I I don't adhere to Noma
but I agree that there's some truth to
it there are vast uh Realms of science
that are religiously neutral but there
are also questions that arise in science
that are that have philosophical
worldview or religious implications and
it's at that intersection that I think
that are some of the most interesting
questions the kind that you address on
your podcast for example and that's what
this book is about what what does what
can science tell us about those big
questions one things I appreciate about
some of the interlocutors opposite me
um and that would be the the uh very
overt new atheists is that they do a
great job of framing some of those big
questions so for example Richard Dawkins
says the universe he asserts that the
Universe has exactly the properties we
should expect if it bottom there was no
purpose no design Nothing But Blind
pitiless indifference a blind pitiless
indifference just a metaphorical way of
describing what Scholars Call Scientific
materialism the worldview of scientific
materialism that says that there is at
bottom nothing but matter and energy the
matter and energy are the things from
which everything else comes and the
material the physical Universe has been
Eternal is eternal and self-existent it
doesn't require an external cause to
account for its origin or existence now
that's a very provocative claim and a
very interesting one because what doc is
essentially saying is that metaphysical
hypotheses every bit as much as
scientific ones might be testable by
reference to observations that we can
make about the world around us and he
asserts in fact that the metaphysical
hypothesis of scientific materialism is
testable but it comports beautifully
with what we would expect to see if that
hypothesis were true when we go out and
look at the natural world and that's
actually a an excellent I use that quote
as a framing device in the book because
I want to argue just the opposite that
there are at least three big discoveries
that we've made about biological and
cosmological Origins that are not what
you'd expect if a materialistic
worldview were true but rather comport
more nicely with the expectations of
theism and those three discoveries in
the book are that the Universe likely
had a beginning that it's been
fine-tuned
from the beginning and subsequently and
subsequent to that for life and that
there have been large bursts of digital
information into our biosphere that made
new new forms of life possible and I I
look at those three big discoveries and
suggest that they comport more nicely
with theism and therefore provide what
philosophers call epistemic support not
proof but uh evidential or epistemic
support for a theistic worldview what
level of epistemic support is is it you
know possible to say you've achieved a
status tantamount to you know
evidentiary support uh in that you know
they say people say oh that's just
circumstantial evidence but you know as
I understand in the American you know
juror system there's a certain amount of
of circumstantial evidence that upon a
certain amount of it uh will constitute
enough to at least be dispositive in
certain legal circumstances so at what
level would there you know rise to be
the level of evidentiary support coming
from
epistemological support and maybe just
Define you know both both of those uh
yeah that's that's an excellent question
especially coming from a cosmologist I
mean you know that in your field you're
reconstructing often events that took
place billions of years ago and you you
don't have the the luxury of being able
to do a controlled experiment or an
experiment or control laboratory
conditions you have to go back you you
reconstruct the past based on the clues
that are left behind whether it's the
cosmic background radiation or or other
things and I actually did my PhD thesis
on origin of Life biology and the
Historical Method of scientific
investigation that's used in fields like
origin of Life research or evolutionary
biology or archeology or forensics or
cosmology there's a whole class of
disciplines that depend upon uh long
after the fact circumstantial evidence
in order to reconstruct processes and
events that took place a long time ago
Stephen J Gould said that speaking of
evolutionary biology said the historical
Sciences reconstruct uh the facts based
on the clue that are left behind so um
so people think well that makes it a
lesser type of science well maybe but
oftentimes circumstantial evidence can
be very compelling and it is it is in
this in the following under the
following conditions epistemologically
um
often the problem with reasoning from
effects backed causes is that there may
be more than one cause that can explain
the same effect the type of inference
you use when you reason retroductively
from effect back to causes is known as
in logic an abductive inference now
abductive inferences can be uh grossly
under determined there can be many more
causes that might explain the same
effect and in that case you're stuck in
circumstantial evidence isn't very
compelling but the
the historical geologists and
evolutionary biologists in the 19th
century uh refined that method and they
did so by showing that if you compared
competing hypotheses against often a
wider Ensemble of evidences you could
narrow down the candidate explanations
and in a and in the best of cases you
could infer to a best explanation this
method known as the method of multiple
competing hypotheses is used
instinctively by people in for example
cosmology or evolutionary biology and it
does allow us uh in in some cases to
make very definitive inferences about
the causal uh uh events in the past that
explain the the the the the Ensemble of
Clues and evidences that we have in in
the present so circumstantial evidence
can be very powerful and it can be
dispositive if you're in a position to
make an inference to the best
explanation where you have after an
examination of an ensemble of of Clues
only one plausible uh explanation for
the evidence at hand
right and I see this a lot in a kind of
fallacy of of insufficient evidence uh
playing out but more on a practical
level in other words you might find a
lot of scientists as Union you know as
mentioned in the book and some of the
most preeminent scientists are are
mentioned in this book are are some of
them are friends of mine uh you know
despite the the the the folks that I
associate with my often and uh and and
yet they'll say things like you know I
mean just I'll bring up or sir Roger
Penrose he hasn't commented specifically
on this book but uh to me but he was you
know one of the first if not the best to
really popularize this idea of the
Exquisite fine-tuning or low entropy
state of the early universe that seems
in great conflict with the uh with the
theory you know of of inflation which
seems to suggest that you know this the
entropy created during this early
evolutionary you know process in the
universe of its expansion by you know 35
orders of back magnitude in a
microscopic fraction of a second that
that's almost you know a death blow to
that theory
um and and you do mention those uh those
concerns in the book as as you know kind
of
um reasons to doubt the kind of Universe
from nothing which we'll get into in
just a bit however
um you know what you don't talk so much
about is that sir Roger came up with a
alternative cosmology which does away
with the evidence uh or it does away
with this disposes of the uh entropy
challenge to the inflationary cosmology
and it actually involves a universe with
no beginning a Multiverse in time which
he calls a cyclic Universe which he
calls conformal cyclic cosmology
featuring an innumerable number of uh of
of Aeons eons as we would say in the
states and uh but but I don't see much
made of that in fact I see you know
predominantly the evidence that you put
forth in the book for a singular origin
of the universe which you know at first
blush might be considered uh you know
kind of consistent if not proved or you
know posited by the by the Bible
specifically the Old Testament so uh
what do you make of the fact that you
know what one cosmologist can do another
can undo in other words we used to think
the universe was infinite it was static
unchanging uh Hubble the standard lore
comes along shows even Einstein was
wrong
um so any any point and and now then
later on uh folks like uh beta and gamov
and came up with with the theory of the
evolution of the uh very early synthesis
of elements then we had Hoyle who's in
the book and then Burbage my late great
colleague here at UCSD
coming up with uh quasi-steady state
universe and we see this going on and on
and then we had inflation now we have
cyclic cosmology or the bouncing
cosmology at Paul steinart also in the
book uh so tell me what you know why
should we trust this science this
argument that you're making right now
when history shows time and time again
as Mark Twain said that cosmology at
least is rhyming that you know you it's
dangerous to say there was a single
beginning uh despite all the the proofs
in there there's counterproofs from
everybody else so why should we trust
the cosmology which you thoroughly
explore and explain in this book it's
really a magnificent treatment of our
current understanding but again Stephen
it's our current understanding and what
one cosmologist can do you know in the
past another can do better now first I
do address the the cyclic cosmology of
uh Penrose first in a long footnote and
then I have extended research notes that
yeah with the book They're going to be
posted online and so it's uh obviously
very important to keep current with the
most current thing things
um and I can come back I can come back
to that in a bit but the the big the big
picture broad stroke uh answer to your
question is that what I've done is not
I've made an argument for the theistic
implications of modern cosmology that
does not depend upon a specific
conclusion about there being a beginning
or not what I have constructed is what a
philosopher's uh sometimes call a robust
argument meaning that multiple multiple
predicates lead to the same conclusion
and and so I show that as best I make
the argument from a preponderance of
evidence both from observational
cosmology and from theoretical physics
uh drawing on the singularity theorems
of the 1960s and 70s which are
conditional
um and they're conditioned upon general
relativity and there are reasons that
you we uh might not extrapolate all the
way back to the beginning if we accept
that there could be a quantum theory of
gravity in the early you know pre-plunk
time part of the universe but I also
also make the argument that that the
back extrapolation that is being made in
observational uh cosmology that gets us
to a big bang and the
um the the movement towards an infinite
curvature which is the implication of
the singularity theorems are indicators
of the beginning and then then there's
also a third line of argument which is
the board guthful Lincoln theorem that
doesn't depend on the kind of energy
conditions that are necessary to make
the singularity theorems work it depends
only on special relativity and basic
geometric considerations that also
implies that there was a beginning so we
have multiple lines of evidence pointing
to a beginning but then I say but if you
don't accept that there was a beginning
except that there might not have been a
beginning then and that in this era of
quantum gravity
um we should be exploring sort of of
quantum accounts of the origin of the
universe but then I show that those
accounts of the universe though they've
been uh promulgated by uh sort of overt
scientific materialists they actually
have latent theistic implications
certainly idealist implications do you
want to say that the Universe has come
out of a universal wave function and
then
um then you have to ask well what is the
universal wave function if you say the
laws of nature or laws of physics
explain why there is a universe rather
than nothing uh well what are the laws
of nature what what what kind of form
can they have before there is an actual
physical universe and this is a question
that was raised by Alexander volinkan
himself one of the proponents of quantum
cosmology uh in fact I've got I've got
the quote here it's really provocative
in the absence of space time and energy
what tablets could these laws of nature
be written upon the laws are expressed
in the form of mathematical equations if
the medium of mathematics is the Mind
does this mean that mine should predate
the universe but in that account the
universe comes out of a mathematical
abstraction or a universal wave function
which is the solution to a prior
mathematical equation that wheeler
DeWitt equation which is an analog to
the Schrodinger equation in ordinary
quantum physics Berlin can makes this
provocative observation however if we're
saying that matter space time and energy
come out of essentially map mathematics
and Mathematics is the realm exit is
conceptual and exists in the realm of
the mind is our new account of the
origin of the universe actually
presupposing the existence of a prior
intelligence or a mind he doesn't answer
that rhetorical question but
interestingly Hawking who is also a
proponent of quantum cosmology was
sensitive to the same concern when he
said what puts fire in the equations
that gives them a universe to describe
in our experience math by itself has no
causal Powers it's causally a nerd so
deposit math is to posit something that
in our experience only exists in a mind
and minds are the things that do have
causal power so have we by circumventing
one sort of cosmological account that
leads to a theistic conclusion on one
basis namely that there was a definite
beginning or Singularity before which
there was not matter space time or
energy to explain the origin of the
universe now we have a different
cosmological account but it for
different reasons implies the prior
existence of mind and as I show in the
book even there's even some deeper logic
to that and that to get a universal wave
function you have to solve the wheeler
DeWitt equation but the wheeler to
weight equation is a functional uh
differential equation that has an
infinite number of solutions and can
only be solved if there are boundary
constraints placed on that equation and
the boundary constraints are chosen
selectively by the quantum cosmological
modelers to give a universal wave
function that includes a universe like
ours which is their condition of saying
that we've explained the universe so
that input of information by the
modelers I think is actually quite
significant because it suggests that to
to get a universe like ours out the
other end you've got to put information
in and the information is coming in the
modeling from the mind of of of the
theoretical physicists so yeah what what
I've shown is that in a sense
many roads to Rome you've got you've got
different cosmological models but they
all have if you if you probe them deeply
enough they they have implications that
are not strictly materialistic in point
in the direction of mind so yeah we
let's go deeper in that
um I just want to remind everybody to
talk about Dr Stephen Meyer The
Discovery Institute and author of
Darwin's doubt signature in the cell as
well as uh the upcoming book or now
today's uh released just released fresh
off the presses as they say uh Return of
the god hypothesis we're going to talk
about that word return in a moment uh
and because I think it's provocative I
want to ask you to uh to visit Stephen
on the web on Twitter we'll have his
links on the YouTube version otherwise
uh please do subscribe to this podcast
wherever you're getting it and leave a
review that's what helps us get great
guests like Dr Steven Meyer and others
like Lawrence Krauss who I presume will
come on and present the form of rebuttal
he plays not an insignificant role in
this book and he's a controversial
character a self-declared militant
atheist and one of the ones who I think
um although I I agree with your most
recent you know mentioning of the
wheeler doing equation which is
something you know that's not super well
known to most certainly most practicing
experimental cosmologist and yet is an
example of something which I've
encountered quite frequently where there
is sort of a teleological
imposition that's place that you once
you have an idea uh for example the
Hocking heart will no boundary proposal
which features prominently in this book
or in uh you know the everettian many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics which is another kind of
quantum mechanical
and you know a set of equations or
framework perhaps is the best way to
describe it that could potentially
According to some explain the features
of the universe we do observe so when we
when we look at it um the the the
challenge that I have for you is that
again that you know there's nothing that
says Willard DeWitt is is the ultimate
expression any more than there was
anybody who who said that oh Hawking
hartle
um uh made this made this beautiful no
boundary proposal what need then for a
Creator as you as you mentioned in the
book many times and I have tremendous
challenges to Hawking but I'm afraid
that you know you're you will leave
yourself exposed to you know people who
are not as as friendly as I am and
they'll say things like well no one
tells you that wheeler DeWitt is correct
in other words there might not be a
universal wave function first of all
um you know how could you interact with
it how could you parameterize it in what
type of a hillbrook space does it exist
well I agree with you that the challenge
to Krause and and all um you know who
popularized Lincoln's idea he wasn't the
originator of those ideas the universe
from nothing was that it presupposed the
existence of a Hilbert space of a math
radical entity of the laws of nature and
I find it very weak tea as you Brits or
you're American but you spend enough
time in England to be an honorary Brit
um and uh as they say so it's weak to
say well okay so now here's this one it
feels like a Critic will say you're
cherry picking you're saying oh because
the wheeler DeWitt equation describes
the properties which a universe must
have and all quantum mechanical systems
are undeniably subject to initial value
conditions and boundary conditions
um and uh that that they'll say well
okay so what so we learn to win or wrong
just the same way that Hawking and
Harlow are wrong so why are you cherry
picking which physicist you choose to
get your evidence for the uh the Mind
behind the universe if again if it's
Eternal just like no the stupid question
that people who created God well God
doesn't need a Creator right so you
wouldn't stipulate that there has to be
a mind that creates the mind that
created the matter uh so anyway how do
you overcome that objection that there's
no saying that we'll now it could be
epistemologically sufficient or could be
uh parsimonious to believe that but
there's no evidence for it we have no no
treatment no no ability to to ascertain
whether or not the wheeler DeWitt
equation is as fundamental as the
Schrodinger equation in that it has
predictive power in the domain in which
attempts to be magisterial over which
again what I'm attempting to do is not
to say that wheeler DeWitt is
necessarily right in fact in uh near the
end of my treatment with this I raised
some questions about whether this
application of quantum the analogy
that's drawn between ordinary quantum
mechanics and the origin of the universe
is is apt at all uh because there are
some dis analogies and in an ordinary
quantum mechanical system you have uh
you have a detector you have something
emitting uh you know electrons or
photons you've got you have a an
experimental apparatus you've got double
slits in the quantum cosmological case
you have nothing at all you have just
the mathematics of of uh Quantum quantum
physics that you apply to try to explain
the origin of the system rather than
describing a system that already exists
um but the point that I make is that if
you take this as an as an alternative to
the body of evidence that we have
pointing to a beginning
uh and say well there's a different way
of giving a cosmological account then
oddly that that account also leads to a
theistic implication
um
so
um the the and then in a sense what I
presented in the book is what I call
I've called elsewhere cosmological
trilemma uh the preponderance of
evidence that we have from observational
astronomy and from developments in
theoretical physics in both special
based on both special and general
relativity does point to a beginning
it's and it suggests uh that is the most
likely conclusion and I I think there is
a good argument for theism based on the
origin of the physical Universe at a
finite time in the past
um but if you don't like that conclusion
if you opt for a different account and
the the main account that's been given
as an alternative to the beginning is
one that tries to circumvent the
beginning with with a a a a a Quantum
physical account of the origin of the
universe that then also has an uh a
theistic implication now a third
approach to that is to say well as you
mentioned uh maybe all the possibilities
that are described by the universal wave
function exist in some possible world
the many world's interpretation and in a
separate chapter I show that if you go
many worlds you end up essentially with
absurdities like boltzmann brains and an
inability to make any predictions or
explanations of a phenomena in our event
or in our in our universe you end up
having absurd science destroying
consequences so you can't absolutely
prove the existence of God but the
consequences of denying the existence of
God as a theoretical postulate at least
is
um is a system of physics which ends up
eating its own which ends up destroying
epistemological reasons our ability to
rely on our own reasoning capabilities
about the world around us so at the end
the choices between God and science or
no God and no science so um
that's that's the sort of argument that
I construct in the book now there are
obviously the other thing that I I'm
critical of in the book is the the
tendency among some theoretical
physicists to create kind of
mathematical Castles in the Air based on
zero evidence
and then say well because I can create
these medicines that that provides a
better account of things than say what
we are getting from your field
observational cosmology which are these
strong indicators of the beginning well
maybe so but at some point you have to
weigh the epistemological weight of the
speculative mathematics against the
evidential arguments or the evidential
uh just uh considerations that we have
coming out of observation astronomy
so I'm not and this is where I think
it's very important to point out that we
if if if the standard here is absolute
appendectic proof of the kind you get
reasoning deductively from mathematical
axioms
um you don't get that you don't get that
in science you don't get that hit for a
science-based argument for the existence
of God but what I'm arguing from is the
preponderance of evidence and showing
that if the best indications we have are
of a beginning and if the the main
alternative conclusions that we have or
the main alternative uh models that have
been proposed as to explain away the
beginning both have theistic
implications then we have a strong
argument we have good evidence for a
theistic conclusion even if we don't
reach the standard of proof which is
again unattainable both in science and
in science and in what you might call
Natural theology science-based Arguments
for God's existence
when I think about the you know kind of
approach that atheist scientists
self-declared militant or otherwise uh
take Stephen Hawking and speaking of
edifices in the sky I mean no one was
better a kind of uh slipping than a
slider by an unsuspecting lay audience
than Stephen because he was so uh
charismatic he was uh so brilliant and
he was so accomplished and such a
brilliant writer I only recently fit I
started reading A Brief History of Time
in 1988 uh when I was a teenager you
know and and I stopped reading it in
1988 and then I picked it up again in
2020 and uh and and I started reading
and I finished it and found it you know
oh these objections are trivial so I was
like congratulating my you know all it
took is becoming you know a full
professor of physics that uh but he's
actually a wonderful writer and uh but
the sophistication needed to understand
uh it's far beyond the fact that he
would say things that uh such as any
equation in your book cuts the
readership by half but any mention of
God doubles the amount of readers for
the book uh and of course I I only later
came to the conclusion of what he was
doing uh was really a sleight of hand
and it was um I believe somewhat dis
dishonest perhaps intellectually to do
what he did and I can say this because
uh I wouldn't I wouldn't expect that you
would say it although you hint strongly
at it but you're too much of a gentleman
to mention it and speak ill of the Dead
I love Stephen I am having on the first
author of a critical biography of him
called Hawking Hocking sort of about the
business of Stephen Hawking which I call
Hawking Incorporated he calls Hawking
Hawkings Charles seif at New York
University anyway he'll be on soon I
think he his book comes out a week or so
after yours uh but the the problem I
have with him is that he would use in A
Brief History of Time this Hawking
heartle cosmology as a way to obviate
the need for a Creator as he said if God
has two roles according to Stephen
Hawking who was not a great Theologian
although I'd point out that he he
thought so much about God that he
actually was in Israelite because the
word Israel in Hebrew means wrestles or
struggles with God and nobody struggled
Morely God than Stephen Hawking and in
fact the last word words of his book
that famous book probably one of the
most popular science books in history
sold three times more copies as you
pointed out than Richard Dawkins blind
watchmaker or The God Delusion uh sold
over 10 maybe 12 million copies to date
now uh the lobster best sellers yeah
yeah it was and it made a whole
publishing company and a whole industry
of popular science writing which I
benefit to this day so at the risk of
you know uh of killing the the Golden
Goose I would say you know he in that
book the final three words are mind of
God in other words if this is proven to
be true uh that uh in back in 1988 he
believed that the Hawking heart of
cosmology would obviate the need for God
because God had two purposes one was to
instantiate the universe and the other
was to instantiate the laws of physics
the latter he disposed of according to
him in The Grand Design uh another book
with very strong theistic overtones and
atheistic overtones but speaking of of A
Brief History of Time in that book he
goes through what I only later really
recognizes you know after going to
graduate school basically
as he was doing this mathematical trick
of transforming time in a calculational
sense from proper time from physical
time which we enjoy and right now and we
can do experiments on and we can observe
things like time dilation and other
relativistic effects and he converted it
to this imaginary space which is purely
used for mathematical purposes to solve
equations which otherwise cannot be
solved without these techniques known
officially as Wick rotations to The
Experts playing at home and then he said
well it's just a mathematical trick and
then literally Stephen a page later it's
and now we see that there's no boundary
to time and therefore there is no need
for a Creator
um speaking harshly and as I assume you
know we'll find out when I read the rest
of Hawking Hocking which talks about him
as a commercial entity uh and uh but he
was not immune to using God as leverage
to influ to increase the influence of
his books and his thoughts in that book
that that that argument is really
falling on death ear deaf ears and worse
than that Steven maybe you would comment
on this is that in the revised updated
Edition in 2016 he not only says that uh
the more you know there's more evidence
than ever for the No No boundary theorem
uh but there's also evidence more
evidence for M Theory and inflation and
I point out this is two years after the
bicep 2 Affair that I play a big role in
so you do indeed yeah what about what
about this need to to have Vindication
to have proof Etc why do why do you know
sort of these uh the headlines you know
appear on page one God is dead there's
no God Hawking says and then the
response to the community falls on deaf
ears if at all on page B17 of the of the
Saturday edition
well that was one of the things that you
mentioned Lawrence uh class a minute ago
and I'm indebted to him for
uh getting me into this uh whole subject
of quantum cosmology I've been I've been
studying it a bit but in prepping for a
debate I read his popular book and then
that took me to the Lincoln and then
that got me not only I I was fortunate
enough to attend the lecture series that
Hawking did in preparation of the
release of A Brief History of Time When
I was a grad Student in Cambridge so
I've been aware of this for years but
um uh in prepping for a debate with
Krauss I ended up getting into the
technical papers on Quantum cosmology
and that's reflected in in the last
three chapters of this book and one of
the things I was shocked to find was
that this idea of the idea that the wick
rotation that eliminates in a in an
intermediate step in a longer
calculation the implication of uh a
singularity but only in the domain of
imaginary time or in the complex domain
of imaginary numbers
um that that
implication that he drew from that in
the Brief History of Time played
absolutely no role in his technical work
with hartle that was something that was
purely offered for public consumption
and yet he as he pointed out in the book
itself uh the the idea of imaginary time
and the the uh the detection of the
space-time geometry that is possible
during that intermediate step in the
complex domain has no physical meaning
and yet from that Hawking drew a
metaphysical implication namely that
there was not a beginning to the
universe and therefore there was no
Creator uh but then he acknowledges that
when you complete the mathematical
manipulation when things are converted
back into the real time in which we live
The Singularity reemerges and this is
one of the things that was actually also
very interesting is that the singularity
is presupposed in all of the quantum
cosmological modeling they don't
eliminate it it's only in this popular
popular work and if if I could just
cycle Circle back to the previous very
astute question about well you know
there's always a new cosmology how can
you draw any significant conclusion from
the whole you know body of work in
cosmology when things are constantly
changing one of the things that's that's
not changing it's a constant is the need
to account for the specificity of our
universe as we find it and specificity
in mathematical terms is in a sense um
it it's a rarity of condition among a
vast Ensemble of possibilities and no
matter which cosmology is invoked there
is a need to there's a what's called The
Cosmic winnowing problem how do you
window among all those possible
ensembles of conditions and and and
possible states of Affairs how do you
account for our universe emerging out of
all this mathematical possibilities and
that problem is is ubiquitous it cuts
across the grain of different
cosmological models you find it in
Multiverse cosmologies where the
Multiverse is is
invoked whether it's based on
inflationary cosmology or string theory
or the combination of the two so you CR
you construct a Multiverse uh uh
cosmology to explain the fine-tuning but
then it turns out that you need a
universe generating mechanism to
generate the new universes in the
Multiverse and those generating
mechanisms themselves require prior
fine-tuning so you have the the need for
specificity the indiction and it's left
unexplained and the same thing occurred
and this is what fascinated me in the in
the cosmological case you can you can
circumvent the beginning problem but
only in the case of a deeper information
problem you have to you have to account
for the origin of the specificity that
is included in in the case of quantum
cosmological models the universal wave
function so
um so some of these problems that are
necessary to account for the origin of
the universe at all why we have
something rather than nothing and why we
have a specified something rather than
all the other things that could be are
not eliminated by any cosmological
Theory and and instead continue to beg
the same types of questions questions
about the origin of specificity of
information where in our experience we
know of only one cause for the origin of
information for the origin of
specificity in that sense or the origin
of fine-tuning and that that that causes
a mind so there's a kind of
incorrigibility of the same type of
problems in all the cosmological models
and that's that's that's what I meant
earlier when I was referring to a kind
of that what I done in the book was
construct a robust argument one that was
not dependent on one model versus
another but rather upon the need to
solve certain basic classes of problems
that are only solved in our experience
by the by the postulation of of mind or
intelligence so I'm talking about Dr
Stephen Meyer the The Discovery
Institute author of Darwin's doubt
signature in the cell and the latest
book Return of the god hypothesis let's
get to that title word return because
you know for many of us we never started
off with a god hypothesis and uh it's
often made a great deal of and you talk
about this in the book The God of the
gaps and how even the great Isaac Newton
who you know folks like Krauss disparage
you know as a as a wanton torturer of
counterfeiters and even I've been known
to poke fun at his uh alchemic
alchemical Explorations as well of
course he was uh you know phenomenal
scientist but you know it's often been
said that he was able to patch certain
halls in the theory of universal
gravitation by only invoking uh theories
of of God's intervention or Angels
supporting matter distribution now I'd
heard that in the context of the static
Universe the apparent static Universe I
hadn't actually until you brought to my
attention this kind of offhand comments
by Neil deGrasse Tyson and others of you
know this this failure and that you know
kind of that of how Newton stymied
scientific progress because of this can
you say something about the invalidity
of that uh actually the the lack of
scientific uh curiosity or or good
scientific practice and just accepting
these folklore table tales about Isaac
Newton and his supposed appeals to the
god of the gaps
it's amazing right I've heard this this
story about Newton invoking either the
action of Angels or the direct action of
the deity to remedy an insufficiency in
his laws of of gravitation because as he
examined the solar system he saw that
there were certain points when you'd get
the outer planets and conjunction that
would make the whole thing stable and at
that point he would he would uh
postulate the direct uh and specific
idiosyncratic action of God to to
stabilize things and then the solar
system could continue to to work
according to the laws that he had
otherwise discovered
um I went I've been suspicious of this
for a long time because uh
when I was in grad school my uh one of
my PhD examiners in her tutorial said if
you miss Newton's theism you've missed
everything he was he was devoutly
religious yeah but he was also what the
whole point of the principia was that he
was he was arguing that the mathematical
Harmony of the universe the mathematical
principles that were evident in the
universe displayed the Andi work of God
so to say that the mathematics the the
mathematical laws were insufficient and
that they required episodic
interventions in interposing of divine
will to remedy uh uh uh instabilities in
the system was contrary to his whole
program of research so I was always
suspicious of this story and so I
decided to look into it myself I got
into the principia and lo and behold he
actually argues that that the planetary
system he he he he does point out that
there are these perturbations that that
arise from time to time as the planets
the outer planets get into uh certain
alignments but he says let doesn't
matter the the system as a whole is is
stable on the order of millions of years
uh for you know he says for vast
eons of time and he never posits an
episodic intervention of the deity to to
remedy
the irregularities the irregularity in
the in the planetary system that a real
an irregularity that would not be
captured by his his law of gravity so
it's just a myth
um but so your earlier question about
the word return the uh the book the
title of the book invites
um interest in a story and the story is
that quite contrary to the depiction of
the relationship between science and
religion that's offered by for example
contemporary new atheists or by late
19th century historians
um stories of science now recognize that
uh uh theistic Concepts specifically
judeo-christian Concepts that were part
of the milieu of Western Europe from
roughly 1300 to 17. under 1750 were
crucial to the rise of modern science in
particular the concept of lawful order
the idea about the there are three
metaphors that are commonly used and you
find them in the writings of uh Kepler
and Galileo and Boyle and Newton
metaphors like the laws of nature or
nature perceived as a clock or a great
mechanism or the book of nature all of
these are metaphors of theological
Origins there's a there are laws of
nature because there's a law Giver there
is a sustaining uh that the the deity
has understood to be sustaining the
regularities that we see is not an
explanation for irregularity but a
deeper explanation for why nature is
uniform in the way that makes science
possible another key concept that came
out of this period of the Scientific
Revolution was the concept of
intelligibility that uh the early
natural philosophers mechanical
philosophers people would say they would
call scientists believe they could study
nature and and that nature would have
had reveal its Secrets because there was
a built-in
rationality or design in nature that was
the product of the Divine mind the same
mind that had endowed in us rationality
so there was a principle of
Correspondence there was rationality
built into the universe and we being
rational creators made in the image of
the rational Creator who had made the
universe that way could understand the
order and design that he'd put into it
thus Kepler spoke about uh the High
Calling of the scientists was to think
God's thoughts after him so these
theological Concepts and are were
crucial to the the rise of modern
science the development of systematic
methods for studying nature and that
perspective uh I think was largely lost
in the late 19th century early 20th
century the story of the book is the
story of discoveries that I think should
and are beginning to rightfully bring
that perspective back so there's a kind
of art to the story that theistic ideas
helped Inspire science a lot of that
theistic perspective was lost in the
late 19th century with with figures like
Huxley and Darwin and uh in other fields
Marx and Freud but much of that is now
beginning to come back as scientists I
think are again opening their minds to
the idea there could be purpose in
designing the universe after all
is it a valid argument to say that uh an
absence of understanding of how a deity
could instantiate these processes is a
strike against the god hypothesis in the
following sense so uh let's stipulate
that the Universe began either you know
in a finely you know tuned initial
condition in the inflationary cosmology
or in the cyclical episodic cosmologies
of of Penrose of steinhardt of Turok and
many others uh let's just stipulate the
the universe emerges and that with the
proper you know characteristics and then
uh the universe is kind of a boring
place for hundreds of thousands of years
and even at that time when my bread and
butter my bread was buttered so to speak
when the cosmic microwave background is
produced the formation of of hydrogen
still not much happens uh for another
400 million years when galaxies begin to
form and then and then you know there's
a surfite of galaxy is in the observable
universe we have no evidence for life or
anything and any other planet in our
solar system uh even let alone in other
solar systems in our galaxy let alone in
other galaxies in the current time in
our present Universe let alone in the
past or the future of our current
observable universe but let's just say
the universe is pretty boring uh and
then if you're just kind of as I like to
do let's talk about me uh just focus on
the earth nothing much happens the Earth
you know coalesces out of a
protoplanetary disk a bunch of dust
comes together billions of years go by
um yeah and then uh all of a sudden you
know some molecules come out of the
primordial soup uh perhaps uh you know
with information I'll even stipulate
there's information there uh that was
cell cellular digital information in the
form of the genetic code
um
all this playing out by the laws of
physics which you argue are very finely
tuned I should point out there's a
colleague my good colleague Fred Adams
at the University of Michigan who claims
that the actually the evidence for
fine-tuning in cosmology is not quite as
as stringent as as made out and we'll
talk about that some other time because
I think it's a detail especially as it
pertains to this rambling question that
I'm asking so the universe is pretty
darn boring for you know for about nine
billion years until the Earth forms then
the Earth forms and again of where the
Pinnacle of creation if we are the you
know the planet which as you believe
will host the Messiah I believe the
Messiah you know will you believe he'll
come back I believe uh he's yet to come
but yeah exactly you know we could ask
him when he comes as Avi lobe my friend
the quoting uh Ellie weasel has said
um you know when he comes we'll ask him
is this your second time or your first
and then we'll finally know uh sort it
out yeah so so this the Pinnacle of
crazy but how does God interact in your
view as a as a philosopher Etc very very
by the way to the audience out there I
might be rambling but the book is not uh
the book is as deep in cosmology I mean
we're talking about Wick rotations
complex planes couchy integrals and then
is equally kind of fluid and maybe even
more so conversant with the biological
implications because that was your
really your domain expertise in graduate
school but anyway
God is kind of patient right uh and he's
waiting and then uh and then all of a
sudden the code becomes active and then
we've only had civilization for the past
few hundred thousand years I don't think
you deny Evolution obviously uh but you
believe it's directed by a by a mind uh
and and even the laws of physics are
tuned and that requires a mind to tune
uh but I want to ask you how does the
deity interact in other words he was
fine-tuning 14 billion years ago nearly
and then but the Pinnacle of what he's
waiting for comes about in the last
hundred thousand years so what round up
these are Big Numbers it's basically the
entirety of the universe for the laws to
actually matter uh in other words you
know forget about dinosaurs we I don't
really care about that if we are the
Pinnacle we're the only entity with mind
that is conscious that is conscious as
Homo sapiens means we are conscious of
our existence and that we are existing
therefore we know we're gonna die now
we're the only animals we're the only
creatures that can do that so with a
pinnacle why would God do it in this way
you know why why how would he do it
because I think it's fair to ask how you
know is he in a laboratory is he is he
experimenting if so you know how how
does it get instantiated the mind is it
just like this roll the dice it came up
so finely tuned because he's omniscient
omnipotent and everything else that he
knew eventually there'd be a you and me
in a zoom call that we could chat on in
other words how is the Mind able to uh
account for water yeah for the
teleological purpose that we should
exist
let me speak first about the time
question because I have I have uh you
know friends to my uh friends to my
right if you will who are uh uh old to a
young Earth creationist View and they're
often troubled by the great amounts of
time that it elapsed from the beginning
of the universe to the first appearance
of life on Earth and uh I think you
could ask that question coming from uh
the opposite perspective but to me I
think the the great expanse of space the
great expanse of time that that you know
we have lots lots of galaxies that don't
seem to give any evidence of Life lots
of planets that uh
not seem to have the right conditions uh
our planet does seem to be very
privileged as one of my uh my colleagues
put it in the book privileged Planet uh
but to me it speaks of a kind of divine
extravagance that the whole great big
universe with 13.8 billion years of time
that preceded us was leading up to a
teleological endpoint so I don't find
that the the amount of time that's
transpired from the beginning until the
appearance of life on Earth troubling uh
but there's a uh there were Concepts
theological Concepts that existed prior
to any of this discussion that I think
were helpful and they were part of the
Scientific Revolution the idea that that
um there were two powers of God that
were relevant to understanding nature
one was called the potenciordanata the
ordinary power of God which was posited
as the explanation for the regularities
that we see in nature that God's hand
was was for the most part hidden in that
but yet God was behind the the
regularities what we call the law the
laws of nature are a mode of divine
action and then theologians also spoke
of something they call the potencia uh
uh absoluta or the Fiat power of God
where God was capable on occasion of
acting as an agent within the orderly
Concourse of nature that he otherwise
sustained an upheld
and so I think we have evidence of both
powers of God in our physical Cosmos and
certainly the fine tuning of the initial
conditions of the universe and and there
I I also I know about Fred Adams and I
also know um you've looked at the book
fortunate Universe by um Luke Barnes and
uh his uh Cambridge grads supervisor his
name is slipping my mind Sharon Lewis
yeah they were guessing yeah Lewis yeah
yeah yeah yeah and they've you know the
terrific uh pairing there with a theist
and a materialist discussing the
fine-tuning but they they they argue
that the the atoms's position is really
an outlier at the end of the book say
whether you're a materialist or your
theist here's a great list of fantastic
physicists who all see the fine-tuning
was a real thing and it has to be
explained one way or another whether by
a Multiverse or by theistic Design
whether by many universes or one God
um but in any case the point is I think
in the fine-tuning and I and for me in
the origin of life and the origin of the
digital code I think we see evidence of
discrete intelligent action everything
we know from experience uh shows that
information especially in a digital or
alphabetic form and that's what we find
at the foundation of life and DNA and
RNA I mean this should this is a stop
press moment in the history of biology
when we discover that you know the
secret to heredity the secret to how
proteins are built is actually a complex
information storage transmission and
processing system is run by literally
digital code that is being expressed in
accord with an independent symbol
convention that we now call the genetic
code this is an extraordinary Discovery
and yet every day men and women get
together and do it for free uh yeah yeah
yeah well exactly exactly so uh you know
where did the information come from that
problem has stymied origin of life for
church this is what I did my PhD on it's
what the book signature in the cell was
all about even uh new atheist is
prominence Richard Dawkins have
acknowledged that we have no idea from
an evolutionary point of view how life
first originated from simple uh
non-living chemicals although as Darwin
himself pointed out you know this better
than anybody but he said it's no
objection to speak of the origin of life
as not being understood within the
theory of evolution one might as well
criticize the origin of matter and you
know would like to point out we
understand the origin of matter now but
but is that a god of the yeah is that a
god of the gaps argument type of
argument I think on Darwin's part it's
more materialism of the gaps he's saying
well we don't we don't understand the
origin of matter so why shouldn't we
have to come up with an explanation for
the origin of Life uh in in fact we
don't understand the origin we still
don't understand the origin of either
from a materialistic point of view but
as for the origin of information we have
a wealth of experience as to what causes
is information to arise the great
information theorist Henry quasler who
was one of the first information
theorists to apply that the information
Sciences to an analysis of molecular
biology says that in our experience he
says information habitually rises from
conscious activity and we know this from
and this is part of what we know and
should be helping to inform us as we
think about the origin of information in
a biological context whenever we see
information whether it's in computer
code or in a hieroglyphic inscription or
a paragraph in a book or information
that's embedded in a radio signal and we
trace it back to its source we always
come to a mind not a material process so
when the discovery of information the
foundation of life in every living cell
including the very simple simplest ones
uh I think is is evidence of of the
activity of a mind of intelligence and
uh in fact it's this this connection
between information and intelligence is
presupposed in the search for extra
terrestrial intelligence they're looking
for information embedded in radio
signals and if they find it they're
gonna they're gonna conclude that that
it has an intelligent Source from
another another galaxy or planet or
something so
um I I think to get back to the broader
question you asked I think we have
evidence of of
a discrete Divine action at the
beginning of the universe and very
possibly after that especially with the
the the the origin of the information
necessary to get life going in the first
place
yeah and you see this also I won't uh
the labor the point but the simulation
hypothesis is also a presupposition
which I think ultimately you know it's a
it's a it's a design Theory it's a
theory design Theory design yeah and it
brings up all sorts of interesting you
know theological questions of theodicy
of the simulators you know would they
create evil but but again you know I've
had this argument from the left I say
with Sean Carroll you know who said that
you know God is not a good theory he so
I've asked him Point Blank you know what
are the odds of the Multiverse is a true
explanation for the uh origin of the
laws of nature and our physical universe
and he says 50 50. I said what are the
odds of God's existence and he says less
than uh one percent so we won't rule it
out obviously but he'll say things like
well
um can you envision a simpler Universe
can you envision a simpler universe that
could exist be via Occam's razor if you
like which which I often point out you
know uh it's more like a hatchet than a
razor as employed by most people but
nevertheless having you know a simpler
Universe he would pause it you know an
empty Hilbert space to which I'll say
well who creates the Hilbert space and
you know and he really doesn't have a
good example yeah he'll say things oh
come on you know where does that come
but it is true they're they're you know
I I think the and he's he's I would say
he he I would say is not you know as a
pacifist atheist and that he's he's not
interested in in converting people uh to
to atheism as as Dawkins or or cross
might uh openly suggest they are and yet
he'll say things like well what is the
purpose of the Hubble Deep Field Galaxy
you know 65 252 over there on the left
uh you know the cosmic wallpaper as we
call it uh what what's the purpose of
that Galaxy what's the purpose of uh of
you know the 40th excited state of xenon
uh what is the purpose of CP violation
in Cobalt 60. you know why are these
things exist
um is it you know God's just having fun
I mean extravagance is one thing but you
know as we know there's no information
without energy there's no creation of of
order you know without destruction
reduction of entropy and that requires
energy so you know is it just the
proficacy is it show God's showing off
you mentioned before it's sort of like
almost like a flourish uh the
magnificence of it all but it would seem
very profligate and so what what is it
or I think you might answer but I should
let you answer but uh but we don't know
in other words we can't know why God
would do it but what would be the
purpose of wasting I mean it's it's like
lawns in the Western Hemisphere were
created you know by as a byproduct of
royalty demonstrating that they didn't
need to use their their their their
agricultural resources to grow food it
was meant to show resplendent abundance
in their creation so what is the purpose
of cobalt 60's parity violation what is
the purpose of xenon's 40th resonance
what is the purpose of that Galaxy over
there in a universe with a mind it would
seem quite wasteful
well our approach is not to try to
assign a purpose to everything that we
see in the nature in nature but rather
to detect action of intelligence where
the evidence the distinctive Hallmarks
of intelligence are present
um as to the rest maybe it is Cosmic
wallpaper but the Hubble Deep Field's an
awfully beautiful piece of wallpaper I
mean it's really you know so yeah I
pointed out to Sean you know I have a
colleague who studies that Galaxy I love
I have I have a PowerPoint I do on your
field on cosmology
they have a beautiful picture of the
Hubble Deep Field I think it's gorgeous
you know
um there is extravagant Duty in in the
universe and but
our my work the work of other people who
work on intelligent design is not trying
to assign a purpose to every last piece
of the universe but rather to detect
activity of intelligence where it is to
be found and I think it is certainly
found in the origin of life and
certainly found in the fine tuning is
certainly found I think at the beginning
of the universe so
um so rather than uh say how did God do
it in that sense we're trying to detect
that there was a mind behind it and then
in this book what I do is is ask the
question well what is the most likely
identity of a des of the designing mind
that is revealed by these these features
of the universe that display distinctive
Hallmarks of mine and that's where I say
I I don't think it's a space alien I
don't think it's even just a deistic
Creator when you look at the you know
Dawkins actually in a film uh uh several
years ago was interviewed by Ben Stein
and he said Ben Stein asked him about
the problem of the origin of the first
life and Dawkins acknowledge that that
there isn't an adequate materialistic
evolutionary explanation for for saying
and he said you know it might be that
there's a signature of it Mrs Dawkins
speaking there might be that there's a
signature of intelligence in the cell in
in which case it would have had to have
come from another an alien intelligence
that itself was evolved by understanding
idea
um that's that's unsatisfying in this in
in two respects uh and I argue against
this in the book as it was taking it
let's take it seriously as a
metaphysical hypothesis hypothesis first
it pushes the question of the ultimate
origin back one generation out into
space without answering it
um and it leaves it unanswered whereas
the theory of intelligent design uh
because it's the only cause does
generate information and that is mine
um but secondly any intelligence within
the cosmos
cannot account for the evidence of
design that precedes it in the
fine-tuning of the laws and constants of
physics and the initial conditions of
the universe that into that evidence of
design points in a Transcendent
direction Something beyond the universe
or to a Transcendent Multiverse but I
have uh uh reasons that I lay out in the
book for preferring a theistic design
hypothesis is an explanation for the
fine-tuning over and against the
Multiverse in particular that the
Multiverse requires Universe generating
mechanisms which themselves require
prior unexplained fine-tuning so the
fine tuning never gets ultimately
explained by the Multiverse hypothesis
and yet there is one type of explanation
that accounts for finally tune systems
in our experience whether they're French
recipes or exquisitely crafted pieces of
Machinery or digital code and that is
again what we mean by fine-tuning is a
small probability system uh that
achieves an overall function a
discernible function and when those two
things are joined we talked about that
as fine tuning and we also know an
experience that those types of systems
arise from mine so I think yeah although
I I think I think there are reasons to
prefer theistic design over the
Multiverse I don't think it's 50 50 for
one and zero for the other I think
there's reasons to prefer one well to be
fair to Sean he said one percent or less
so he didn't quite say zero he's too
smart to say zero right to be fair to
Sean Carroll for another reason I I very
much appreciate his work because unlike
some of the really Ardent Defenders of
of scientific materialism who take it as
axiomatic and take anyone who disagrees
is as ignoble and ill-informed uh Carol
is very clear that scientific naturalism
or materialism is itself a metaphysical
hypothesis it's a worldview that needs
to be defended and I I appreciate him
for that reason because he puts it on
the table and says all right let's look
at it what's the evidence for and it
gets he makes the case and with such a
person you can have a really a very
constructive conversation yeah he's a
genuine uh intellectual and somebody
that I have great respect for he's also
a phenomenal scientist and a yes mentor
and and he endorsed my book so I can't
say anything so you have you could you
can only say good things and you you you
gave me a nice endorsement so yeah
although with endorsements you know
endorsements are kind of funny because
you know because of the zero-sum nature
of reading books yeah I can't read your
book and read my book or a customer care
you know so it's kind of dangerous right
you don't want to be too glowing in the
praise of of another's work now your
your book is really phenomenal as I say
you may not agree with everything but
you'll have your work cut out for you
and uh and for me you come away
sharpened uh for for the better from
this debate I want to push back a little
bit on the mind and the code anyone
who's ever been to the DMV and picked up
a license plate you know I'd take a
license plate the other day uh for uh
for my wife's car getting renewals 6zq
you know txy four wow that's really
improbable I mean to find that guys you
know that license plate is extremely
important you know one in a billion
chance of trillions of chances actually
with all the letter combinations it
could be and yet I got that very one and
obviously there's no mind you know
behind that it might have been a random
number generator and of course random
processes can be created randomly truly
by the radioactive decay which doesn't
require a mind unless you want to get a
really Prima facial causes uh but let's
just restrict it to naturalistic
explanation and yet there's no real
design yes maybe it was didn't have a
thousand letter sequence but but it
wasn't and and it wasn't really wasteful
it wasn't using you know uh
hieroglyphics it wasn't you know just
demonstrating that the power of the mind
so I want to ask you you know that's at
some level do you think
it's possible to derive uh not just a
non-deistic God but a personal
judeo-christian God from these arguments
that you make in this book or from
intelligent design generally speaking
the advocate for a single God as
atheists will say is an acute kind of TR
you know tried and true way they'll say
I'm I'm I'm not only a monotheist I
actually believe in even fewer Gods Than
You Stephen I believe in no Gods uh so
in the sense can you can can intelligent
design uh follow down a path that will
lead to a personal God uh in the sense
of God who cares about the of perhaps
interacting with the laws of nature
maybe not for Brian Keating uh but for
Jesus Christ in your opinion uh you know
and so forth a God who intervenes
personally to achieve a a set of of
goals or Commandments uh as in the Ten
Commandments that we adhere to
um can you get from ID to you know A.D
uh in that in a direct path or is it as
difficult as proving God's existence to
be real
um well there's actually two questions
in your in your question so let me take
the first one about the detection of
design the detection of false positives
with design yeah a design inference
um the work that my colleague uh William
demsky has done in his book The Design
inference shows that yeah it's
absolutely possible uh to to get a few
you know a few letters or a few things
to arise that look as though they're
designed and the question is do you have
the probabilistic resources to explain
such things by chance and often you do
but there also becomes points where
there's you're beyond the reach of
chance and this has been widely
recognized by origin of Life researchers
themselves there's a great quote from uh
the Scottish biochemist Karen Smith
where he says you know a few uh you can
easily by chance generate a few short
words cat ran uh you know I used to do
this with my students reach in the
Scrabble bag and pick out a pick out
letters and occasionally they would you
know in in a demonstration in class
they'd get the word cat or ran or
something like that but I was attempting
to show that chance is not an adequate
explanation for the origin of the amount
of information you would need to build
um when protein let alone a full living
cell and so I would always win the
demonstration uh win the argument in the
demonstration by continuing to allow
them to pull letters out because as
Karen Smith pointed out if you need a
vast amount of information is the amount
of organization or information required
increases chance becomes increasingly
implausible and demsky has shown that
there's an absolute cutoff where you
exceed what he calls the probabilistic
resources of the universe and so in my
in both signature in the cell and I
reprise this argument a bit in uh
Richard of the god hypothesis I show
that there's actually some sophisticated
second order probabilistic reasoning
that allows you to eliminate the chance
hypothesis if you have a a very highly
specified thing that you're seeking
through a random search and
um you're only able to sample a small uh
minuscule proportion of the total in
this case sequences that are relevant in
the time available since the beginning
of the universe till now uh counting
every interaction of Elementary
particles uh as as an event it you can
show that there aren't enough events
since the beginning of the universe to
sample more than the calculation I made
more than 10 110 trillion trillionth of
the total relevant sequences in
searching for one modest protein in that
case you can eliminate the chance
hypothesis it's more likely than not the
chance will be false it's overwhelmingly
more likely than not that it's a random
search will fail in which case it's
overwhelmingly more likely that the
chance hypothesis is false and true so
there are there there are ways of
guarding against the kind of false
positive inferences to design that you
were just describing with the license
plate illustration as to the second
question of how you get from an
inference to
um design simplicitor or to a generic
intelligence which is as far as I take
the argument in my first two books in
Darwin's doubt and signature in the cell
how you get from a generic designer to a
designer that has the attributes of
uh a God that would be recognizable to
theists well that that is the argument
of the new book and what I do there is
broaden the the using the method of
inference to the best explanation or
multiple competing hypotheses that I
described earlier in in our discussion I
broadened The Ensemble of relevant
evidence from just the biological
evidence the evidence of design we have
long after the beginning of the universe
to look at the evidence that we have
either from the beginning of the
universe or soon after as the laws of
physical chemistry are taking shape and
showing that that uh that you have
evidence of design prior to the origin
of any possible imminent intelligence no
space alien could be responsible for the
fine-tuning of the initial conditions of
the universe or the laws and constants
of physics upon which its very existence
depends and so that candidate designer
isn't very good in which case you're
looking at something that is is pointing
beyond the universe uh and and then I I
think you start to to look at evidence
for Transcendent intelligence but also
we have evidence of design long after
the beginning so you I think when you
take the Ensemble of evidences jointly
you have evidence for both an active
intelligence but one which is
transcendent and those two two uh
attributes jointly I think uh give you
attributes that we uniquely associate
with with the deity
oh that's fascinating Stephen you know I
love talking to you I could talk to you
all day I would be upgraded and possibly
uh physically abused by uh many people
more intelligent than me AKA my wife if
I don't go and pick up one of my
children how to pick up some kids yeah
that's right uh but I do want to put a
pin in some of these conversations
because I I do think it would be great
to have more debates or discussions with
you about
um about these ultimate issues in in
life in existence I think they're so
much fun I think when you take out the
hostility of the militant atheist and
you and you do so with uh with with love
and with true interest and understanding
the other's point of view I find your
work fascinating again as I said in my
in my blurb uh you might not agree with
everything uh but the but the point
being this is these are the the issues
that make life worth thinking about and
living and understanding because not
just in the Pascal's wager sense of
things I think that if you don't examine
these things uh it's sort of you're
you're you're not making use of the full
computational power it's like buying an
iPhone and oh it has a camera I don't
need that uh oh it can browse the
internet I'm just having it you know I
just have it for uh for the notes app uh
but but Stephen I I love talking with
you I love meeting you in person uh
about uh three weeks ago uh but now I
want to ask you if you are willing to go
into the impossible and answer the final
three questions that I ask all my
treasured guests who come on the into
the impossible podcast
and to hear Stephen's answer I learned
this trick from our mutual friend Ben
Shapiro to hear Steven's answer you're
going to need to subscribe uh to my
mailing list which you get at Brian
keating.com Steven is a subscriber as
are many of my guests so by the way if
you want to be in great company with the
wonderful brilliant nine Nobel Prize
winners who have been on the show uh
billionaires brainiacs ordinary people
like you and me uh please uh subscribe
Brian keating.com and you'll get a link
to the answers that Stephen will provide
to the thrilling three so if you're not
going to listen to that or subscribe
signing off enjoy the rest of the
universe but for now those subscribers
now stay tuned for Steven's answers to
the thrilling three you can get a link
to it down here or to my mailing list uh
right there Stephen I want to thank you
so much for going into the impossible I
wish you wish you the success and
blessing and happiness that you are so
richly deserving them and I hope we'll
meet again for more of these stimulating
stimulating impossible conversations and
I hope it won't take 14 billion years of
evolution and design for us to come
together again